why does story structure exist
I think that story structure exists
because people have expectations
obviously it all started in my opinion
with Aristotle's Poetics you know he
described the 3x structure he described
you know the way stories move but it's
not just that it's the fact that we want
to see a journey and
regardless of what story structure
you're following or what school of
thought you're following you want to see
a journey you don't want to see someone
doing something and then not see an
ending you know you don't want to see
someone just remain the same through an
entire story so I think that you need
structure because you need
pattern of change you need to have a
protagonist that is going through
something and because of the events of
the story they change they Arc they grow
in a way that by the end they don't
necessarily become a whole new person
obviously but they've been affected by
those events and they have overcome
something or they have changed in a way
or something has happened to them so I
think that structure is that is the
expectations that we have but also
because that's the way life works you
know it's like from birth till death you
expect that Journey so there are steps
to follow and I think that's what we
want to see in a story obviously we're
not watching someone literally from
Death from birth to death but we're
watching even if it's a snippet of their
story we still want to follow a
beginning middle and end
and just like in life it's not just
constant action there's resting points
exactly and there's times when nothing's
happening it's totally boring and then
there's other times where you wish it
was boring and so it's kind of so those
are kind of like the turning points of
the story right like something happens
to you when we would call that maybe the
inciting incident right that disrupts
the world of your protagonist and then
maybe we get a little leeway because
they're trying to assess what they want
but then the midpoint comes and
something terrible happens and we go
into a new Direction and then things
like that you know so like we're having
this ups and downs but hopefully through
that your protagonist is changing right
there's some flaw that they have and
some goal that they have that probably
oppose each other so we're trying to
track that Arc and that change
what confuses writers most about
structure
I think that for writers the problem is
that they're either trying to follow a
formula
or they're forgetting that structure and
character are connected
so yes there are a lot of formulas out
there right the three act structure the
eighth sequence approach save the cad
here is Journey so many more
but I don't think screenwriting should
be you know a fill in the blanks type of
thing it should be more creative than
that obviously those are great ways to
kind of map out a story and I use them
myself when I'm writing I love the eight
sequence approach which I'm super OCD
about things and I liked mapping it but
it's also because it works and it gives
you ideas of turning points at the same
time I don't believe things should be
you know at minute 12 that should happen
I mean at 24 that should happen it's not
that level of exact science but I think
that when you're tracking uh you know
structure and when you're working with
things like that you are trying to get
somewhere in that sense you need a path
you need to follow something like that
so I think that one of the problems for
writers is that
structure uh needs to be linked to that
character as I was saying so they kind
of like
make things happen to the character
instead of the character making things
happen and that's what I see the most so
it shouldn't just be that things you
know are changing in the world it should
be the way the character is doing things
that are impacting him and are changing
things that are happening so a hero
should be there and kind of like giving
obstacles to themselves in a way you
know we talk about breaking bad right
Walter White is his own enemy in a way
and by the end he becomes his own
antagonist but he is constantly doing
things that are just impeding what where
he wants to go and how to get to that
goal at one point obviously he gets
money crazy you know and power crazy and
then he starts doing things that are
going to get him eventually caught so if
we're tracking a structure those are the
things that we should be thinking of
that change and the character that if
we're thinking about a feature obviously
there should be that womb at the
beginning or that flaw that the
protagonist has that we're tracking
through these turning points and that's
why we need structure and that's one of
the things that writers tend to forget
they should be the turning points should
be emotional turning points for the
protagonist they shouldn't just be
changes like oh this big things happen
that's external to the characters it
should be linked to them
so we were talking about Juno at another
section and let's suppose we decide to
write a screenplay Juno 20 years later
maybe she's uh got a pretty good paying
job somewhere
how would we make it where is things
start happening to her or she's
initiating it so she gets a letter from
someone saying
I'm the child you gave up for adoption
or she's looking for that child what
would you what would make it more
interesting
I think that in that case it's
interesting if I were writing this uh if
she go where to get the letter because
that disrupts her world right maybe
she's think bad let's say she gets this
letter right maybe she gets the letter
at a time where she's thinking about
having kids with
a spouse at that point right so getting
this letter disrupts her plans because
she was thinking about having kids
which obviously for her at that point
would be hard right she gave up her baby
years ago when she was a teenager now
she's at a point in her life where she's
ready to have a kid she has a wife or a
husband or whatever a partner and she
wants to have a family right what if
that happened and then she gets the
letter from the child she gave up I want
to meet so what do you do you know and
that becomes something about her yes
there's an external thing that happens
this letter that comes but it will
directly affect her emotional core wound
and flaw obviously for her she might
have always wondered you know about what
if I had kept this baby what if you know
so getting that letter will shake her
world but she still needs to Ark and
grow she needs to for example accept
that she gave up that baby and accept
you know that things turned out a
certain way
at the same time maybe she needs to come
to terms with the fact that yes that's
something she had to do in the past but
now she's in a different position and
she could have a baby maybe when she was
having that discussion when the letter
came she wasn't sure and her partner
wanted to have a baby but she's still
struggling with can I have another baby
uh maybe should I have another baby I'm
imagining you know all of the things
that would go on in her head like
should I be having a baby I already gave
one up is it okay if I have one you know
all of these things that she might be
questioning are the things that are
going to move the story forward and
along right so every Turning Point later
would have to do with that then maybe at
the First Act Turning Point she will
meet this kid you know and then that
will be her journey that she'll set out
through the remainder of the story right
act two is where that Journey will get
explored then maybe my the midpoint
she realizes she is pregnant or
something like that you know and then
what will she do this time around and
things like that they just could keep
evolving but all tracks through her
emotional Journey which again is linked
to that core wound that she has
connected to what happened in her past
and that she needs to overcome by the
end of the story and that in that climax
you know she would be hopefully you know
realizing okay I'm okay with my past I
can move forward and I can have a life